I'm Anthony Mason with Gayle King and
Tony to copal only on CBS this morning
we're hearing for the first time from a
Connecticut man accused of killing a
hotel worker in the Caribbean
Scott Hapgood is charged with
manslaughter in the death of Kenny
Mitchell Hapgood claims Mitchell
attacked him at a resort on the island
of Anguilla in April in front of his two
daughters investigative correspondent
and a Warner is here Anna what did
happen could have to say good morning
Anthony Scott popke describes his past
four months as terrible but says he
hopes to clear his name
he spent the past several months out on
bail but is traveling back and forth to
Anguilla this week ahead of a court
appearance on Thursday we spoke to him
yesterday during his first trip back to
the island a trip required as part of
his bond agreement all I did was defend
my young daughters in front of an
attacker that was crazed and desperate
and I have to just hold on to that fact
I would do it again and thank God I was
in the room when he came in
Scott Hapgood says he was anxious about
returning to Anguilla for the first time
in four months ever since he says he was
ambushed by a resort worker there I was
on vacation relaxing with my family and
attacked at knifepoint in a private
hotel room on a exclusive resort after
the incident on April 13th a spokeswoman
for Hapgood said a worker identified as
27 year-old kenny mitchell showed up
unannounced in uniform at the hotel room
around 4 p.m.
claiming he was there to fix a broken
sink before carrying out his sudden
violent attack they said he was armed
and demanding money
four days later authorities charged
Hapgood with manslaughter he was later
released from jail on 74 thousand
dollars bail it's certainly the most
terrifying event other experienced not
not just the attack but the way I was
treated on the island the
the time I spent in jail the threats
since the frustration with dealing with
the local judicial process and the local
government hapgoods family says he was
stabbed bitten several times and
sustained many bruises over his arms and
chest
Mitchell's autopsy report shows he was
beaten and choked to death but a
toxicology report released by the
islands attorney-general
also shows Mitchell had cocaine cannabis
and other drugs in his system it shows
his blood alcohol content was more than
two times the legal limit in the u.s. my
son wasn't into those things
I know candy candy wasn't into those
things less than a month before the
alleged attack an ex girlfriend accused
Mitchell of rape that case was pending
at the time of his death and the
ex-girlfriend later called it a
misunderstanding Mitchell's mother Rena
says her son was a considerate man and a
loving father with no history of violent
behavior I am just praying and hoping
that my child get justice no matter
what's up how could says justice for him
would be clearing his name we look
forward to a lot of evidence that hasn't
yet been made public getting to the
public I think it will have an immediate
and dramatic impact on people sent him
in towards this this incident our
producer Sean Herbert tells us many
locals are angry over this case and were
skeptical that Hapgood would return for
his court appearance
Hapgood is back in the u.s. today but is
expected to return to Anguilla
tomorrow the Anguilla crime scene
department said it had no comment on
this toxicology report such a bizarre
story for so others ID on either side
yeah yeah but he is going through the
process and he's returning to Anguilla
as right as he wants to go his name yeah
requirements he has to come back a
certain number of times
very slowly bond agreement yeah thank
you Anna